Google is going all-in on gadgets a
today's big Hardware event the company
debuted a bunch of flagship products
designed to work seamlessly with
software with the help of artificial
intelligence it all starts with
reimagining hardware from the inside out
the company kicked things off by
unveiling not one but two new smart
speakers starting with the Google home
mini it's just like the Google home only
smaller and cuter it makes Google home
more accessible to more people in more
rooms LED lights underneath the fabric
top let you know it's listening and it's
also touch sensitive the mini comes in
three colors coral chalk and charcoal
and it will retail for 49 bucks
pre-orders start today and you can find
them in stores starting October 19th
if the mini is too small for your tastes
Google's smart speaker now comes in a
super-sized version too
say hello to max our biggest and best
sounding google home ever it comes
packed with two tweeters and a pair of
four and a half inch subwoofers the
whole thing is about the size of a
shoebox and it looks as good on its side
as it does standing up so you can adapt
it to your space and pairing two of them
lets you listen to your tunes in stereo
that's if you can afford it
the Google home max will run $399
pre-orders start today with shipments
beginning in December
Google's family of gadgets added another
member in the form of a new high
performance Chromebook it's got a twelve
point three inch touchscreen display
that swivels 360 degrees so you can use
it like a laptop stand it upright on
your in flight tray table or flip it all
the way over into tablet mode the whole
thing weighs about two pounds is around
one centimeter thick and comes with
Google assistant Baker right in it also
works with Google's new stylus the pixel
book pen the Chromebook starts at $999
in the pen at $99 pre-orders start today
and they'll be in stores starting
October 31st
up next phones the brand new pixel 2 and
pixel 2 XL brings some essential
upgrades to Google's flagship handset
both devices are now water and dust
resistant feature more powerful cameras
and photo software for simulating depth
of field and portrait mode and come
loaded with beefier processors for
running augmented reality apps oh and
they've got a smarter virtual assistant
on board as well
okay Google let's go home sure let's go
your commute home is currently 27
minutes with heavy traffic if you take
us 101 south you have one unread text
message it's from mom it says we'll
bring dessert to dinner tonight here's
where you left off in fresh air
have a safe drive I'm Terry Gross with
fresh air one thing the new pixels don't
have headphone jacks ready or not the
future is coming and that future is
wireless both models come in 64 and 128
gig configurations pixel two starts at
649 and the pixel 2 XL starts at 849
they'll be available for pre-order
starting today pixel 2 will be available
on October 19th with the XL shipping in
mid-november need some wireless
headphones to go with your new phone
Google's got a gadget for that too these
are pixel buds Wireless in ear
headphones that give you a direct line
on Google's voice assistant and playback
controls it also gives you access to
real time in ear translation for more
than 40 languages no idea how well this
feature works in the real world but the
onstage demo looked pretty sweet what do
you think of these cool new headphones
well if you can do em them haiku let me
know ho nude enough to go blah the
headphones last about 5 hours on a
charge and come in a battery case with
up to 24 hours of reserved power like
the pixel 2 they come in white blue and
black they'll cost $159 when they go on
sale in November let's see what else
google also announced a refresh on the
daydream view the company's VR headset
still cost 99 bucks but it now comes in
new colors and features upgraded lenses
and fabrics but the bigger more
surprising news was the announcement of
something called Google clips a tiny
attachable camera that uses AI and
machine learning
to look for photo opportunities so a
laughing baby or an excited dog and
capture the moment for you an indicator
light on the camera lets you know when
it's snapping pictures and all the
machine learning happens on the device
itself which should help with privacy
concerns no word yet on a release date
for Google clips but the company says
it's coming soon and will cost $249 so
there you have it the next generation of
Google gadgets